όταν έμαθα γιατί βεβαίως αναεμενα ότι θα είχαμε και στην κύπρο τα θέματα οικογένια μου
ήταν στην κύπρο τα παιδιά μου είναι εκτός κυπρου με ένα το μέλιμα μου ήταν
ότι έπρεπε να βρούμε λύσεις και αυτές η λύσεις να μπορούν να φτάνουν και να
ποφεληθούν όλοι οη ευρωπόίει πολίτες θαν εξαρτίτως σε πια χώραζούν ξέρετε κύπρο συνένα πολύ μικρό
κράτος μέλος και πολλές φορές το βλέπουμε ότι έχουμε ελλείψεις σε φαρμακα είναι δύσκολο αντιμετωπίζουνται
προβλήματα που σε άλλες χώρες αντιμετωπιζονται πιο έγκαιρα για μένα από την αρχή το μεγάλο
στίχημα ήταν κανένας ευρωπέος πολί της να μη νιώθει ότι ήταν ήταν σε μειονεκτική θέση
για αυτό ήμουσε πολύ συχνή επαφή με τεςς κυπριακές αρχές βεβαίως και με τον υπουργοογείας
τότε και προσπαθούσα να τους καθοδι γώ για το πως έπρεπε να κοινηθούν ήταν μιαπρωτογνωρί
κρίση δεν ξέραμε είχαμε νένα ηό τον οποίον δεν γνωρίζαμε δε γνωρίζαμε αν θα βρίσκαμε
εμπόλια δεν υνωρίζαμε πότε θα μπορούσαμε να βρούμε αυτά τα εμβόλια δεν γνωρίζαμε αν αυτή
η παραγωγή θα ήταν αρκετή για να φτάσει σε όλα τα κρατη μέλη είχαμε πάρα
πολλά ειρωτηματικά και ίσως κάτι πουδεν έχω ποι καμια φορά ήτα εναι καθημερινότητα μας με
την προεδροφόντλαη οποία από την αρχή της φαντιμίας και καθημερίνα χτόμερι στη βδομάδα η ώρα
οκτόμηση το πρωί είχαμε τη λεδιάσκεψη μαζί και με τους άλλους αρμόδιους επιτρόπους όπου ξεκινούσε
και στέλ